hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess uh tournament
we are in the finals and this is the
second match between magnus cross and
indianapolis after a
crazy day after uh day one we are now in
day two and this is the first game of
the rapid so the first game in general
of the second match
and magnus has the white pieces and
already a lot of excitement as
magnus goes for his london system
although uh
sometimes uh characterized as maybe not
the most exciting opening magnus
is able to take down anyone with with
this opening
like we already mentioned even taking
down vladimir kramnik with it
uh in the in the world uh rapid and
blitz championship so let's
see what happens d4 uh sorry about that
uh we have knight to f6 by nipple uh
knight to f3 and now g6 uh we have
bishop to f4
starting the london system we have
bishop to g7 and e3 by magnus we have
castles
uh and now bishop to e2 we have d6 now
preparing to strike in the center with
e5 and the castles here
and now uh trying to harass this bishop
knights to h5 and magnus doesn't go
bishop to g3 but instead
bishop to g5 he forces black to decide
what to do with the knight uh or will he
go h6 g5 to further harass the bishop
which is
exactly what nepo does so h6 we have
bishop to h4 and
g5 now but now not moving the bishop as
this way nepo just eliminates it instead
knight the d2
now saying okay we can trade here but
you have to mess up your pawn structure
in front of your own king
and while this is playable nepo says
okay magnus probably knows this too well
i'm just gonna go back knight to f6 and
now magnus goes knight to g3
so the end of of this uh well sort of uh
harassing contest is that both knight
and bishop stay alive but nepo is
somewhat
uh somewhat well
maybe over extended here on the king
side but but who knows
uh so knight to c6 he continues
development and the knight to c3
and here now that the knight also helps
out with the control of e5 uh he does go
for e5
and now while you can play d5 magnus
doesn't want to close up the center and
then play against
these advanced pawns here for example
something like this closes up the center
completely
but then black can choose whether he
wants to play on the king's side on the
queen side with c6 bust open the center
and so on shouldn't really pose any
problems to black so instead here we
have
d captures on e5 there is one game in
the database where knight to b3 was
played
uh but here the capture is on e5 and it
is as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see uh what what nipple does
with this he captures with the knight
knight captures on e5
and now the immediate f4 which kind of
leaves this e3 pawn to be a weakness but
uh magnus not worried so we have knight
eat the g4
now putting pressure on e3 so this
captures is the idea
uh but magnus not interested in uh
giving up the the bishop for knight goes
to rook to f3 he
uh defends the e3 pawn this way we've
rooked to e8 now
a double attack on the e3 pawn and now
just defending that pawn you could also
consider
e4 but magnus just commonly defends it
and will decide what to do with the pawn
later on
so knight to h5 now putting pressure on
the bishop here also a double attack
on the f4 pawn uh and uh well again you
could do a lot of things here you could
challenge the knight with h3 you could
capture on g5 magnus uh keeps the
tension and just plays bishop back to e1
he doesn't want to give up the bishop
pair
and he is inviting this capture and
capturing here is probably
the best move for naple for example
captures captures and bringing the queen
into the game
uh uh you you have some nice
nice uh development then you could also
maybe go queen to d4 maybe trade queens
bring the bishop into the game and so on
however nepal went for f5 here and this
um
well it looks good but it also looks a
bit too ambitious
because magnus what he plays here is
just bishop to c for
check and now bishop to c4 check is an
extremely strong move because if you
move the king let's say you try
something like king to f8
uh well you you're just not uh you're
just not
uh getting uh getting away with the king
it's such a terrible square for the king
f captures and g5 is coming the f file
might open up
not might will uh and it will just be
pretty terrible if you try something
else like
king to h7 or something like that then
bishop the f7 incredibly strong with a
double attack on the knight and
under rook also goes for king king to h8
so that's not an option so nepo instead
decides that he will not move the king
he will play bishop to e6
but now magnus goes uh uh for just
captures because what
this bishop on c8 was doing was it was
guarding the f5 pawn even though it's
not currently attacked but
one capture on g5 and the pawn will be
under attack so this is what magnus goes
for with captures on e6 captures and now
uh queen to d5 looks and looks
interesting but it doesn't really do
anything black just defends it and then
next you're going to play
c6 d5 push the white queen away and just
continue the game
so instead magnus goes for h3 he
challenges this knight to go back
knight g to f6 and now f captures on g5
with an attack on the knight and also on
the f5 pawn
so h captures and finally magnus grabs
it real captures on f5 so this is uh
this is why that f5 uh move was was a
bit too ambitious
because it doesn't matter what you do
you always lose it and losing the pawn
is probably the best for black because
if you tried moving the king instead of
trading over the light square bishops
uh you're just dead lost so here at
bishop h6 nepo defends the g5 pawn but
now g4 pushes the other knight back as
well knight g7 and now rook back to f3
guarding the e3 pawn and now this knight
is sort of stuck here you can't go here
you can't go here you can't go here
and it's not uh not at all clear where
the knight
is going so queen d7 by nipple preparing
to double up rooks and the e
file and now knight to g3 preparing to
bring the knight into
into the game via the f5 or g5 squares
maybe even just the po
to support the pawn via the e4 push so
rook 8 to e8 another attacker is brought
to the e3 pawn and now bishop f2 just
nicely defending that
uh and here nipple played queen to c6
just puts pressure
on this on this rook on f3 so if the
queen moves you can capture it
but this is now a completely winning
position for magnus so feel free to
pause the video here and
try to find the idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on finding such
a
such a nice normal move uh and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
uh it's e4 and e4 is quite uh
quite the move e4 is quite the move
because
uh black doesn't really doesn't really
have a good move here for example if
you're not
if you're not careful uh with something
like uh well
the basically white wants to play knight
to d5 and as soon as this knight lands
on d5 it's
just game over for example if you try
something like a6 knight d5
and that's it there's a there's a double
attack here uh which
is pretty terrible in itself point is
you can never capture if captures
captures the double attack just
wins the game and even if you don't
capture if you try some like rook f8 to
defend the knight you're just going to
get bishop to d4 another attacker is
here if you move it let's say knight h7
you're gonna get rooked to c3 now with
an attack on the queen after the queen
moves the
knight and the rook will nicely join up
on the attack on the c7 pawn and once
that happens
you are breaking through here just
captures this will be
under a lot of pressure the knight is
coming into the game via knight h5
knight to f5 uh just a complete madness
so uh instead okay nepal did not play
such a silly move like a6 nipple played
knights to d7
so the knight d5 does not come with an
attack on the knight but still
magnus just played knight to d5 uh and
it was again
uh in this position that ianni pogba
resigned the game
uh and it is what grishok meant with
with his
with the quote above the board he said
that this resignation shows a lot of
respect
as uh well not a lot of people would
resign here they would still try
uh try some things and we'll hope that
magnus can also make a mistake but nepo
says no
i i think that you you are more than uh
more than able uh uh
you know in winning this and i will not
be wasting my time and
energy trying to save this so let's just
turn to other games
and see what happens there here you
resign again because there's not much to
do rook c3
breaks through here on the on the c7
pawn and there aren't all that many
many good ideas on how to go about
defending this like uh
it's really really just a tough position
for example if you move the queen
and you try and avoid it then just
knight captures on c7 you can't even do
that you can't go here
uh it's just uh there's no
move that you can play that actually
helps you if knight the c5 trying to
meet this
rook the c3 idea by just blocking it
you're still going to play rook to c3
and prepare b4 and if a5
then the position just slowly but surely
gets worse a3 preparing b4 to break
through now you can play a4
but still b4 and it's not not much
better a character c
captures again b4 is coming you cannot
stop this it's just it's just hopeless
whatever you do here so this is coming
and on the other hand if you if you
don't
try and stop it there there's not an
active move you can play
you could try some complete madness move
but
nothing really comes to mind here uh
there is no defense against this idea
even though it just gives up a pawn
uh this pawn is like the uh the defender
of the entire position
and uh well then this pawn becomes a
weak then you're just all over the place
and the nipple doesn't want to play this
after knight d5 he just resigns and the
game one of the second match goes to
magnus
which is huge as he already won in the
first match and now he's one step closer
to winning the entire match he only
needs one more point
uh or a point and have but let's say a
win
uh and the draw or the other three games
if they end in a draw then magnus wins
the
entire thing and he is the winner of the
legends of chess tournament on chess 24.
uh so yeah that's uh the game i do hope
you enjoyed it as you can see
london uh the london uh opening it's the
london system
you know it's perfectly playable against
everyone uh and you know you
you either enjoy playing it or you hate
playing against it
so uh once again i would like to thank
uh darryl dobson richie torres
lionel puderbito uh robert stratford and
joseph bassett for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage
of the legends of chess to uh uh
a chess legends tournament on just 24
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the world of chess so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day